[Musique]
au début du siècle dernier une personne
anticipale l'avènement des chars des
avions des voyages dans l'espace des
guerres nucléaires de la télévision par
satellite et même du World Wide Web
Internet
cette personne n'est autre que Eldi
Wells l'auteur de La Guerre des mondes
et j'ai le même métier que lui je suis
futuriste
alors ça ne veut pas dire que je peux
prédire le futur ça on adorait tout ici
il y a pas de souci
c'est que je j'essaie d'imaginer ce qui
pourrait nous arriver demain et le
conditionnel est important
on n'a jamais autant parler de futurs
qu'aujourd'hui
mais pas vraiment pas envie plutôt par
peur le dernier rapport du GIEC dresse
un tableau pour le moins noir des
décennies à venir pourtant nous
n'agissons pas la crise écologique c'est
normal n'est pas vraiment tangible et
nos cerveaux pas vraiment câblés pour
penser le long terme
alors entre ce désespoir qui nous gagne
et c'est bien cognitifs est-il encore
possible de faire quelque chose
je vous rassure la réponse est oui et
cela passe par l'imagination
en effet les imaginaires ont toujours
façonné nos visions du futur ont
toujours façonné ce que nous voulons
voir advenir
qui n'a jamais rêvé par exemple après
avoir vu Retour vers le Futur le
deuxième avoir un hoverboard un skate
volant quel enfant on est dans les
années 80 comme moi n'a jamais
réellement pensé que nos ions des
voitures volantes en l'an 2000
l'imaginaire dominant aujourd'hui c'est
l'imaginaire dit technolibéral c'est un
imaginaire où le progrès de la
technologie équivaut progrès tout court
un imaginaire ou le métaverse
c'est-à-dire le remplacement du réel par
le virtuel et vu comme désirable
or nous le savons tous aujourd'hui la
technologie n'est pas remède miracle
c'est peut-être même le poison
le réveil écologique le réveil sociétal
a rendu cette imaginaire prédateur
d'attention prédateur de ressources
insoutenable à tous les niveaux
il est temps de créer de nouveaux
imaginaires désirables il est même
urgent d'en créer de nouveau
Eco féminisme
ecotopie
solarpunk
derrière ces mots étranges se cachent
déjà les germes de ces nouveaux
imaginaires désirables des imaginaires
ou la technologie serait enfin au
service de l'environnement et de la
Société des imaginaires horizontaux et
inclusifs ou la question du genre est
indissociable de la question de
l'écologie
des imaginaires ou nous reconnectons à
la nature ou pour mieux le dire au
vivant à sa richesse à sa capacité
d'innovation
mais comment faire advenir ces
imaginaires ces futurs qui sonnent un
peu comme des utopies inatteignables
pour promouvoir et matérialiser les
futurs technolibéraux la Silicon Valley
avait un allié de poids la
science-fiction
alors vous ne savez peut-être pas mais
vous utilisez tous un geste inventé par
un film de science-fiction celui-là
reste du zoom
n'agrandit nos photos sur notre tablette
ce geste a été improvisé par Tom Cruise
dans la scène inaugurale de minorité
reporte
dans la Silicon Valley la
science-fiction est partout elle guide
l'innovation les auteurs de
science-fiction deviennent même des
futuristes en chef dans les start-up
le problème de la science-fiction ce
qu'elle nous propose des mondes beaucoup
trop grands pour nous des mondes fait
d'apocalypse de fin du monde de grands
récits
des Mondoux nous n'existons qu'en tant
que spectateur
or si nous voulons créer des nouveaux
imaginaires des nouveaux futurs elles
nous engager nous
nous citoyens nous utilisateurs nous
consommateurs qu'il faudrait nous mettre
en scène nous s'intéresser à notre
quotidien
et c'est justement tout le principe
d'une discipline qui s'appelle le design
fiction qui cherche à renouveler nos
visions du futur le design fiction en
fait c'est le son principe est d'une
simplicité déconcertante nous faire
déménager en 2030
à quoi va ressembler mon appartement
qu'est-ce que je vais avoir dans mon
frigo quel produit de beauté vais-je
utiliser tous les matins en fait le
design fiction cherche à transformer des
visions lointaines du futur en produit
et services tangibles
manipulables immédiatement
compréhensible
pour parler par exemple d'un futur ou
l'alimentation ce serait adaptée au
réchauffement climatique le design
fiction va imaginer et donner à voir
notre repas de cantine en 2030
qui se rapprochement fait de hot-dog à
la spiruline et de burger aux insectes
mais ceci est un autre débat
et en fait pour encore mieux nous faire
vivre ces futurs le design fiction va
transformer ces usages ces parcours nos
journées en fiction justement avec des
personnages auxquels on peut
s'identifier un début une fin pour
vraiment mieux l'incarner pour que nous
puissions nous approprier ces visions
parce que nous le savons notre cerveau
est câblé pour qu'on lui raconte des
histoires
alors tout ça demande un corps
interdisciplinaire des auteurs
évidemment des designers évidemment mais
aussi des chercheurs des autres
prologues des sociologues des
technologues pourquoi
le DN fiction n'invente pas des futurs
il explore les futurs les plus
désirables parmi le vaste spectre de
tous les futurs possibles
quel futur seront possibles et probables
étant donné l'état de notre état du
monde de la démographie nous notre
environnement nous savons certains le
vieillissement de la population le
réchauffement à 3 degrés ou les
migrations climatiques
nous devons faire avec et dans ce décor
quel futur seront possibles et
plausibles étant donné l'état de nos
sociétés qui hésite aujourd'hui entre
frugalité surconsommation entre méfiance
et collaboration ces tensions sociétales
c'est dynamique sociétal nous devons les
intégrer dans nos scénarios du futur
quel futur enfin seront possibles et
faisables étant donné l'état des
techniques et des technologies par
exemple l'intelligence artificielle tout
comme l'ordinateur quantique sont loin
des promesses vanter depuis longtemps
alors qu'à l'inverse en parallèle des
technologies d'édition du vivant comme
par exemple le ciseau génétique crisper
caz9 ça permet tout simplement de copier
coller l'ADN aussi facilement qu'un
contrôle C contrôle V sur votre
ordinateur ces technologies là elles
font des progrès remarquables ce qui
dessine un monde technique réel bien
différent des mythes de la Silicon
Valley bien plus connecté au vivant qu'à
la machine
en fait vous l'aurez compris le design
fiction ne crée pas des futurs hors-sol
il explore les futurs désirables il nous
montre ce qu'il y a de plus radical
d'émergeant il cherche à nous faire
regarder là où on ne regarderait pas il
cherche à faire advenir à des futurs
dont on ignore encore l'existence
et si
par exemple pour lutter contre les
maladies chroniques et l'obésité ont
parié sur la jump food la malbouffe
qu'on transformerait grâce aux
ingrédients synthétiques en nourriture
bonne pour la santé faites de nouveaux
goûts nouvelles textures inédites où
chaque repas sera une expérience ludique
et si contre-intuitivement pour lutter
contre la résistance antibiotique et
atteindre l'immunité collective on en a
beaucoup parlé pendant le covid l'être
humain se réconcilit avec les bactéries
les invitant à sa table les partageant
avec ses voisins sont badigeonnants
allègrement et si pour lutter contre la
pollution liée à l'extraction des métaux
rares le numérique se faisait organique
avec des plantes comme capteur ascenseur
avec des ordinateurs fait d'ADN dans des
cellules avec les whereable les
technologies portatives que nous que
nous avons sur nous qui se
rechargeraient avec notre sueur
un futur désirable ce n'est pas une
utopie ça compose avec un décor qui ne
l'est pas un futur désirable s'embrasse
la complexité ça cherche un équilibre
d'impact positif entre environnement
société économique
en fait un futur désirable c'est jamais
parfait si un futur en construction et
c'est en ça que cet extrêmement
intéressant puisque c'est en allant
chercher explorer des solutions inédites
qu'on pose des questions nouvelles qu'on
ouvre de nouveaux champs de
collaboration de réflexion
les entreprises institutions ou
collectivités locales avec lesquelles
nous travaillons et qui utilisent les
méthodes du design fiction vont par
exemple les utiliser pour aller
identifier des nouvelles technologies à
impact positif
revoir leur procédé industriels ou
encore ou on en parlait repenser un
urbanisme qui nous reconnecterait au
vivant
mais si nous le grand public nous en
parlions nous aussi du design fiction et
de ces méthodes
et si tout simplement nous prenions le
temps
d'imaginer le futur dans lequel nous
aimerions vivre
et si tout simplement nous prenions le
temps d'en discuter et de le partager
avec nos voisins nos amis nos
partenaires à prestidix si vous voulez
si le futur est une prophétie
auto-réalisatrice c'est bien à nous de
choisir la prophétie que l'on veut faire
à devenir
vous l'aurez compris aucun futur n'est
écrit à l'avance le futur ça ne se
déduit pas
ça s'imagine et c'est à nous de jouer
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]